[Music]
so
in the world of inventions we try to
create products that better our lives uh
you know to solve innovation problems to
solve
illnesses and whatnot and sometimes you
know loneliness could be one of those
problems is this another robot
do sex dolls yes continue what no
it has nothing companionship
robot come on dude
is it a bean bag that you could put in
the microwave so it feels warm yeah yeah
when you when you put your insides
inside of it that'd be kind of cool
country's involved in this japan well
why don't you guess what yep
japan japan yep yes japan what do you
think
well beans come from colombia it's a
doll for you gotta hug you it hugs you
it hugs you no okay well i bark out of
my head
it's not sexual there's a hole for
insertion let's just say
it's not sexual but i feel like it could
go in that direction it listens to your
problems
uh no wait it's not sexual but it could
go there really easily
well everything could be sexual it
cuddles you you cuddle yeah i keep
thinking that
like being a massage doll you can cry to
it
oh it listens to your problems nope he
said that no
all right so enter the worst round table
does it listen to your problem
listen to your problem one more time
i think you have a table full of severe
adt people for real
is it a brita filter for your pee
now see actually let's let's write that
down
we'll circle back to that one afterwards
should actually do that i kind of want
to test it yo that's water
the first that was one of my favorite
movies so good that was when the one the
girl had gills
yeah oh she didn't remember what if it
still holds up today i don't remember it
i'm gonna watch it
i need to watch it i haven't even
watched it my friend was a part of the
water world show and then he broke his
teeth yeah
wasn't that one of the most expensive
girlfriend too he's very handsome i
wanted to she knows who he is
it was really teeth are fits now okay
yeah all right back
back to this uh invention back to the
sex doll yeah
my girlfriend and walked i have no
boyfriends
specifically girlfriends and i feel like
very inclusive girls aren't lonely or
what
what about gay guys oh yeah no it's
because there's a lot of incels in japan
and only like two percent is really
banging all the girls
and it holds up that makes sense right
what were you saying there's no hole
involved in this i'm just kidding
i don't know i i don't know i don't know
about the numbers but i do believe you
in
in the sentiment of that yes so
basically this has got to be
in my opinion one of the most in-cell
inventions i've ever heard of if
there was such a category it just holds
your hand
it literally hold yeah you're built they
built a girlfriend's
hand for you to base is it shaped like
this
[Laughter]
let me show you guys some pictures real
quick oh my god so this
is my girlfriend in hand
and it's literally a hand poor dude man
so it's i can't see it dude i can't oh
right the little
there we go so this is a
strap you wear on your forearm and then
there's a lot of
you know mumbo jumbo here that doesn't
even look good and then
that is a synthetic uh skin thing that's
stretchy
that hand looks creepy as [ __ ] they
should have [ __ ]
made it like actually like a girl's hand
before they made it all maybe it looks
kind of like a man's hand
it looks like tails from the crypt hand
like oh they should give like
a manicure and the hand is bigger than
mine for sure that hand looks like it
has arthritis
it does here's another angle oh so
they're interlocking
fingers here uh poor guy and holding
hands now the the design of this thing
is to
cure loneliness for anyone that can't
get a girlfriend and i guess
especially in this day and age in the
pandemic it's harder to meet people yeah
so this is going to solve that problem
if you want to hold hands
and feel a little bit you know is there
a price point on this yet no
no there it's not on the market yet well
it looks like a clear prototype
zero dollars because what's okay if
you're gonna get that you might as well
get a sex doll right
it's true yeah then you get the whole
package well that's why i said this
could turn into
a sex thing too i mean you just gotta
turn it into
this but they already have sex dolls
yeah maybe because the sex doll's so
expensive
that's why he asked about the price
point yeah i'm going to go out walking
with the sex doll
can you walk with that he walked with
the hand yeah would you would you rather
walk around with that on your hand
i don't know man no that's a way i'd
rather just hold my own hand can't you
just hold your own hand
but you can't just be walking around
with body parts you know like that's
weird you don't know japanese people
let me explain to you this product so
this product uh within they'll say we
cannot skin of the hand
of the robot hand yeah because there's
little pores in it they build little
pores
so it could sweat and there's a liquid
there's a fluid that they
inject into you have a clammy hand robot
sweats wow
and there's also heater in this hand so
it's actually worn when you hold it it's
definitely gonna be used for sex
you know what they should they should do
is attach a briefcase to it so that like
it looks like you're just going to work
but really you're holding it
yeah that's so sad yeah that is really
sad there's also a bar so when you when
you walk with it it actually sways with
you
and it pulls you forward or pulls you
back depending on how fast you're
walking
so it feels like you're actually getting
a dog holding a person's hand
get anything else and here's anything
else
get a handball get a hobby get something
dude that is so
funny oh [ __ ] this is how good
technology is nowadays you know wait you
need that big ass bar
too looks like a windshield wiper it
feels like you're not but like going
this way that's like in the way
even the advertisement's creepy as [ __ ]
what you're saying
it's difficult to get a girlfriend
this ain't gonna help you get a
girlfriend i'll tell you that no girl's
gonna buy oh that falls fine
and that's a stretchy material it's like
there's lips on it lips
and this must be a prototype for another
maybe another invention maybe it's a sex
you can kiss a girl you're saying like
something like it's it's it's
all crazy a lot it's human skin
technology
dude one malfunction and say goodbye to
your hand see that's um
yeah oh true another interesting thing
that they said about this
was that um depending on how hard you
grip the
robot the robot can censor how hard
you're gripping it'll grip back the same
amount of strength
it breaks your hand i know so if you're
holding it really hard i'm guessing it
would just
do the same amount of pressure i don't
know about this man that robot's
clinging
crazy i don't know about this at all
and to make it even more uh more creepy
is that
this this robot is compatible with your
phone
where you can download an app and then
jerk you off no no
the app will play exactly yeah that's
that's the add-on the app will play
breathing noises
and clothes clothes rustling and also
footstep noises as you're watching how
lonely are these people
is there really a market for this very
sad joe you have more insight
i don't i know that this news always
comes from japan
but when we go there i have never seen
any of these products out in the open
so i don't know where it's happening
nowhere it's probably happening nowhere
because
just in labs maybe in okinawa
it's happening in okinawa
if you walk around with this hand on
your hand what girl is ever going to be
like oh like that's attractive
that's you all girls are going to be so
scared of that guy no no hold on
unless a girl sees that they know the
product they know what it's for
and then it it like triggers the oh i
gotta rescue him poor lonely man
he needs a woman in his life would you
do that though tiff i feel like i have
that in me
i don't think so oh i think if you saw a
random guy with that you run for the
[ __ ] hills
especially if you look at the guy that
has that hand that
model looks like an average dude with
the hand
if you want to get murdered then you
date that girl i can feel sorry for them
bro that's not cheap there's no way
that's going to be cheap but i'm not
like oh i want to [ __ ] that guy
oh yes i want to [ __ ] it's a pity
date it's a yeah
that's what i'm saying that can turn
into love that turns into jeffrey dahmer
bro
especially i'm talking about like old
tiff like into deep tiff
this [ __ ] would like what about a dude
with a vibrating fleshlight in the
corner
that's creepy that's predatory but how
is that different than that
because it's the same thing this one's
perverted this one's sad they're both
but what's how different is that how do
you not know like maybe maybe this
person
in public he's walking with his hand but
in private at home he's turning it into
like a jack off
yeah i don't like i don't want you want
either of them i feel like it's a
slippery slope if a guy's a he's kind of
promiscuous and he had two hands and
he's a player with these rolls
he's like look i got two i got two
that's hot
[Laughter]
yeah i got two you got two houses
[ __ ] and the guys that only have
one hand he's all like what and then the
hands like
jealous so it grips him tight like stop
looking at her
next we're back oh [ __ ]
sorry honey i don't know man i don't
know
i don't think i could think of anybody
that i know
that would be willing to walk around
with this in public it's not for
like people that are you know
regular it's for [ __ ] really
desperate lonely people yeah
yeah people who can't make human
connection like at all like
super socially yeah that's actually true
then like you wouldn't have a friend
that
that would buy this yeah maybe japan
needs to get to the root of this like
maybe psychologically they need to do
something in their school well i mean
they're highlighting the worst of the
worst right yeah and like also
i think that the shame behind it and
embarrassment it's not the same as here
so if people would want it here they
would be ashamed of it versus in japan
it's like yeah he's got a pocket [ __ ]
yeah i think like
america remember that video that guy's
grandma had a pocket [ __ ] on her
[ __ ] foot
what he did a jk news on this yeah it
was [ __ ] that guy's grandma
yeah well because she wore them like
slippers because because she thought it
was a sock
oh my god if he was recording
but like being like this it's it's kind
of i don't know it's not seen the same
way so they do it proudly
i'm saying and i'm not saying like
america is better like america has a
different set of problems like we're
like way too arrogant as a country like
there's a psychological problem
that we should address uh at the root
but like i feel like all of these just
fix
they they fix the surface issues they
don't like dig deep i think for sure
because
their mental health like understanding
and acceptability
is like way it's already tough here
right yeah but over there
it's even worse like so my grandma was
um
when she had alzheimer's and dementia
and all that and she was
at a home they didn't have a
psychologist
at these locations so i'm like how are
they
like who how are they training these
like nurses so the nurses they don't
even take a class in psychology
what and i was like what so they just
learn how to like take care of people
and service them well and then give them
medicine and that's it
so like i'm like this is crazy because
you know japan's not like
uh you know they're like technologically
forward and all that so you would think
that they would be forward in academia
too
but um they didn't know a lot of things
about
alzheimer's that i knew as like just
taking a psychology class
yeah and i was telling them um the the
nurses and and the staff that was
working there
i was like this is kind of how this
works you know and then they're like
whoa they're like
i wish i learned this in school but a
lot of them are college educated huh and
i'm like how are you guys
working in a well it's not a hospital
but it's a retirement home
and i was like how what are the
qualifications like can we get certified
on like how we should
treat them and and you know how we
should approach them and talk to them
and i'm like that's crazy and you don't
even understand how this condition works
so i think because of that reason a lot
of them
aren't up to date when it comes to that
kind of like
like if it's a disorder or not right
like these these loneliness and whatever
they i don't think they connect the
thoughts like the way we do it
but after you left it like that guy in
pigtails is a genius
no they literally was like can you tell
can you have a seminar and teach us this
stuff
no way yeah
you